d'habitude mais découpés dans le
réservoir ça marche même pas là vous
avez quoi comme essence la moins chère
d'accord oui pas mal mais chez moi
[Musique]
prennent aux
et long moment cole moi je vais bosser
la gamme as tu vas te [ __ ] dans le
canapé et tu veux regarder des dessins
de c'est quoi ça ok on va sonner ils
vont ouvrir à tort alors qu'arte c'est
quoi ton excuses aujourd'hui calais
monsieur des moments très surveillée
mais ça va pas la tête de dire des trucs
comme ça on a dit que c'était fini ces
bleds vêtements classiques c'est
important l'école eh ben pour lui ces
commentaires on ne s'est pas créé chez
bien vous faites enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu restes là pas bougé tu as tort moi je
suis un ami de prune toi t'es qui là
super je m'en fous je réponds moi c'est
ce que je veux c'est mon frère ok
d'accord
vous êtes tous frères et ça en fait
vous êtes juste 3 où il y en a d'autres
[Musique]